foreign
Russia's military has also released
these pictures this morning reportedly
showing a naval missile launch on
Ukrainian military infrastructure Russia
claims it has destroyed weapons at a
military equipment Depot in more region
Russia has hinted that it might no
longer be concentrating on taking full
control of Ukraine instead Focus as it
puts it on liberating the donbass region
in the east of the country which is
largely controlled by separatists our
defense and security analyst Michael
Clarke is here so Russia then saying
that they want to refocus on the donbass
area what will that look like Michael
and crucially what will that tell us yes
if it's true because you've only got
one's statement that may or may not be
the truth of it all but it would make
military sense for the Russians to
concentrate the troops they've got in
theater who are they're far too
dispersed they're not achieving their
objectives but they've got a lot of
troops in theater if they concentrated
on the one area that they started from
which is the donbass region where the
separatists the Russian separatists only
held a third of those regions so if they
then concentrated and took both of the
regions of the donbass the luxansken
Donetsk that would make a certain amount
of military sense it would leave a lot
of other questions open of course as to
whether they wanted this land bridge
between the donbass and Crimea and why
why are they pushing towards Odessa if
they only want the donbass it's full of
inconsistencies however it would make a
certain amount of military sense if
they're not doing very well anywhere
else to get something out of this war
and concentrate on the dumbbells Mike
would be good to get your thoughts um
and the significance I suppose on seeing
those Russian generals with the defense
minister today yes I mean we've all been
saying that the the uh grazimov the
chief of general staff hasn't been seen
since the 11th of March which was true
until a few hours ago and then this
video emerged about eight o'clock this
morning UK time which shows uh shogu the
defense minister speaking to generals
and grazimov is there doesn't look very
pleased but he's there in the middle of
the table
um now this clearly has has been put out
by the Russian Ministry of Defense as it
were reassurance that these people have
not been arrested they're not under
house arrest they're functioning we
don't really know when the video was
made so maybe it's it is what it what it
says claims to be a meeting that took
place a few hours ago maybe it took
place some days ago we just don't know
when we know a bit more about it we'll
be able to interpret it a little bit
more